Just because our server can
listen on every single port, for
any type of request,
that doesn't mean we should.
The rule of least privilege, which we've
discussed throughout this entire lesson,
tells us we should only listen
on the ports required for
our application to function correctly.
We can configure which ports we
want our server to listen to
using an application called a firewall.
Let's imagine this wall is
our firewall application.
And each of these slots is a port.
We currently have all the slots filled,
which means I can't
pass data from one side, the Internet,
to the other, my server.
You could say I'm denying
all incoming requests, but
if I open one of these boxes,
we'll choose port 80 here.
I can now pass information through.
The server on the other side can
now fully function as a web server
with the added benefit of
completely ignoring these requests
that we know we're not interested in.
Let's go back to our terminal and start
configuring our server's firewall now.